Lana says some researchers see shame as
something that is very destructive the
consensus seems to be that it is an
emotion that is always destructive do
you agree with this no that's absolutely
ridiculous and only modern psychologists
and probably social psychologists would
be foolish enough to even dare to posits
that something so absolutely absurd
psychopathy and shamelessness are the
same thing so shame is no emotion is
always destructive any emotion taken to
an extreme can be destructive just like
any value taken to an extreme you know
made into one thing can be disruptive so
joy can be destructive I mean people who
are manic are in some sense possessed by
a radical excess of part of the
promotion and they they get incredibly
impulsive and so and it's terribly
destructive I mean there's almost no
form of insanity that's more destructive
than mania people will go out and spend
all their money all their family's money
and well it engage in all sorts of hyper
optimistic interactions with the world
it will result in their complete rude so
you know people think of happiness as an
untrammeled positive well if you think
of happiness as positive emotion which
is partly true because it's also the
absence of negative emotion if you think
of happiness there's only a good then
you have no idea about the pathologies
of positive emotion and their manifold
and shame it's like if you do something
stupid and destructive to yourself or to
yourself and the broader social
community you should feel shame and you
should pay attention to it and you
should learn from it and if you're not
capable of doing that that then people
should stay the hell away from you
because you're shameless and of course
for most of Western history and I don't
know enough about other forms of history
to also make the same comment to call
someone shameless with it was it was a
tremendous insult it meant that they
didn't have enough sense to be appalled
by their own pathology and there's that
that's just not a good thing at all